this is the third time you've won this
award isn't it guys how are you feeling
evening had a good time we've been
trying not best for about allows what
15-20 years now I grew up with these
guys when he was like this big 7 8 9
years old they started playing both and
these boys have been doing a bit and the
team just got stronger and stronger and
stronger and it's just always a pleasure
it's never ever feigned the great
playing four or five six times a week
then we saw win national titles
we got leading the English side young in
there in the Devon hundred twenty-five
side so it's good you know so I'm doing
sign is pretty good and how does getting
an award like this for the team British
Sports Personality of the year compared
to gate national titles is it just as
important to be recognized locally do
you think is absolutely massive for us
for a side like children for for a
village of smallish olden to win it in
in 2001 2010 and 2012 three times in in
a matter of 12 years it's just
phenomenal it really is for a woman to
get that recognition is really good for
the club we love it in this it's just
massive in terms of Devon as well that
they see that as brilliant and we're
just absolutely living the dream at the
moment and what do you think about
meeting other people in sports men women
young people volunteers here tonight if
you enjoyed that yeah that makes it for
us to be fair you know seeing what other
sports are in team breach you know it's
not just bowls we can get ready cocooned
during sports but it's nice seeing you
know other sports and they have to offer
in team Bridgend and their achievement
so it's nice knowing that they do doing
well not just bowls
yes done thank you very much sir now
what next for shoulder boys club another
national title next year hopefully we'll
be aiming for sir fingers profit well
we're done guys thank you very much and
congratulations again